>> THEY CAME HERE FROM THE
DOMINICAN REPUBLIC, AND 30 YEARS
LATER -- 61 YEARS OLD, FRIDAY
NIGHT BUT WE COULD GO AT
MIDNIGHT WENT TO THIS STORE IN
HARLEM WHEN A VIOLENT CRIMINAL
WALKED IN AND DISPUTE OVER A BAG
OF POTATO CHIPS -- CAPTURED.
HE WAS STABBED TO GUT, IT WAS
CLEARLY SELF-DEFENSE.
IT'S VERY UPSETTING.
THEN, THE THUG'S GIRLFRIEND
SHOWS UP AND STARTS STABBING
HIM, NOT IN SELF-DEFENSE, OUT OF
RAGE BUT THE D.A. CHARGED HIM
WITH MURDER BUT NOT THE
GIRLFRIEND WHO STABBED HIM.
AFTER PUBLIC OUTCRY, HIS BAIL
WAS LOWERED, BUT HE IS STILL
FACING MURDER CHARGES.
THE VIDEO WE JUST GOT MAKES IT
CLEAR THAT HE DID EVERYTHING HE
COULD TO AVOID CONFRONTATION.
WATCH THIS.
>> WHAT'S UP?
>> I DON'T WANT A PROBLEM.
>> "I DON'T WANT A PROBLEM WITH
YOU."
HE THEN GOT THROWN DOWN AND
WRAPPED BY THE NECK
CONTROVERSY -- PRESIDENT OF
STATEN ISLAND, THE BEST BAROQUE,
SPOKE IN DEFENSE OF THEM.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
THIS SEEMS LIKE AN INCREDIBLY
STRAIGHTFORWARD EXAMPLE OF
SELF-DEFENSE.
>> YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
THIS IS WRONG ON SO MANY LEVELS.
THOSE THAT KNOW THE TREND IN
NEW YORK CITY -- BODEGAS, WHICH
WORKED AT -- ROBBED ALMOST ONCE
A DAY.
THEY ARE IN VERY CONFINED
SPACES, VULNERABLE, OFTEN IN
VERY LOW INCOME AREAS.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT VIOLENT
CRIMINALS HAVE BEEN LET GO, THEY
GET ARRESTED, BACK ON THE
STREET, AND ALONG COMES THIS
POOR GUY JUST EARNING A LIVING,
FRIGHTENED, ASSAULTED, TRYING TO
DEFEND HIMSELF.
IF THERE IS ANYTHING -- IT'S THE
RIGHT TO DEFEND YOURSELF AND
YOUR PROPERTY.
RATHER THAN ARREST A WOMAN WHO
STABBED HIM, HE'S FACING 15-25
YEARS IN JAIL.
SOME FOLKS MAY NOT KNOW,
NEW YORK CITY IS COMPRISED OF
FIVE DIFFERENT BOROUGHS.
IF YOU GET A TAX, IF YOU ARE
ASSAULTED, YOU HAVE THE RIGHT TO
DEFEND YOURSELF.
INSTEAD LONG ISLAND -- FOR SOME
FOR SOME REASON, WE HAVE THIS
IDEA WHERE THE VICTIM BECOMES
THE CRIMINAL AND THE CRIMINAL
BECOMES THE VICTIM.
>> IT'S PRETTY OBVIOUS THAT
MEMBERS OF POLITICALLY-FAVORED
GROUPS -- AND WAS NOT A MEMBER
OF THAT, SO HE IS BEING
PUNISHED, BUT IF YOU ARE THE
D.A. CANNOT TERRENCE CRAWFORD --
WHO ALSO STOP SOMEBODY IN
SELF-DEFENSE --
>> IT SEEMS TO BE THIS ABSURD --
IT'S INSANE.
ANYONE WITH A HALF AN OUNCE OF
COMMON SENSE LOOKING AT THIS
VIDEO HAS TO FEEL FOR THIS GUY
AND LIKE YOU SAID, RATHER THAN
CHARGE THE PEOPLE WHO INITIATED
THIS THREAT, THEY ARE NOW
LOOKING TO PUT HIM BEHIND BARS
FOR 25 YEARS.
SOMETHING'S GOT TO GIVE THEY
WILL RELEASE IMAGES OF CITY TO
FOREIGN LAND IT'S A GREAT CITY,
BUT TOO WE HAVE SEEN --
>> IT WOULD NOT BE HARD TO FIX
THIS.
REWARD GOO